Boris Johnson has described his new team
as a cabinet for modern Britain but how
can it be when two-thirds of them were
privately educated just 7% of children
attended fee-paying schools and yet
according to the Sutton trust a tiny
elite made up of the privately educated
a 5 times more likely to hold the top
jobs in politics media business and the
judiciary it costs around 40,000 a year
to send a child to the PM's former
school Eton the average UK household
income is 29 thousand but it's clear the
very wealthy few aren't just buying an
education they're buying access to power
and privilege and it is diminishing and
distorting our democracy Johnson himself
is manifestly unfit to serve but his
sense of entitlement to do so along with
our confusing of class confidence with
actual competence has propelled him to
the top we say we're committed to
equality of opportunity but what could
be more unjust than a small moneyed
elite using a private education as a way
of dominating power in our society it's
time we put a stop to this by scrapping
private schools I I really as a fellow
journalist Rachael I I really like the
way you write but what always kills me
is do massive lefties always miss the
point completely
I mean the point is this that at full
disclosure I've had two daughters at
private school did not go to one myself
reason I sent him to a private school
was because first of all the locals
called were poor and it would have cost
me more to live in an area of London
where the state schools were good than
to pay to go private the question in my
mind always is why do you go on this
massive distraction when the real
problem is how do we think the state
sector and I'm gonna play my regulation
clip from my soul sister Jess Phillips
because she's really got she's really on
this here's what she says austerity
measures over years and years of
degraded school budgets in Birmingham in
Boer
Stockport and Brighton all over the
country to the point where school can't
stay open any longer four five days a
week
this is not something my son's school
wants to do this is something that
they've done after cutting teaching
staff after increasing the numbers in
classes after begging parents and doing
fundraising for money to buy equipment
this is not something that they want to
do so what are you coming in here and
doing that instead of picking on a poor
scholarship boy who just happens to be
her brother who went to a nice school I
mean this is missing a point make the
state school better
before you start worrying about they add
a lot can I just respond to a few other
points you've raised I know everyone has
something to say but the co-authors of
engines are privileged there's a book
about what's wrong with the private
school system and what it's done to our
education system came out earlier this
year they caveat this conversation
themselves by saying really it's not
about who went to private school or who
sent their kids to private school
because then we get bogged down in a
conversation about hypocrisy and that's
not really what this is about it's about
how we going forward but fix our society
and what all these people who have
looked into this subject have identified
is the biggest reason why this of course
we need to invest in the state school
system of course we need to invest in
classrooms make sizes smaller better
teachers better resources but the thing
that is most distorting our education
system is the existence of private
schools because it is enabling people to
funnel their kids to the top my concern
is that your I think your analysis is
correct but what I wonder often with a
lot of social justice causes is they
point to real and present problems in
society why is it that the solution
always seems to be to ban things like
yes there's a problem with inequality
that doesn't mean we ban high salaries
yes there's a problem with private
school privilege doesn't mean we ban
private schools yes there's a problem
with people saying things that offend us
and we don't like should mean doesn't
mean we ban them from university
speeches and the left always seems to
kind of think that shutting things down
is the solution to real social
inequality why not focus on the
opportunity why not focus on improving
the state schools why not focus on for
example
making sure that there isn't a and
privilege granted to people that went to
private school but also why not focus on
some of the positives like yes this may
be a cabinet that has a higher
proportion of privately educated people
in it the previous cabinets it also
happens to be the most ethnically
diverse in history and so that's also a
plus to it as well so at the end of the
day I think that the picture is a
complicated one and I think we should
focus on improving the situation rather
than just jumping to legislative
measures like banning private school
well Trevor told me at the start this
program and one of the phrases that was
banned is I am so frustrated I won't say
that but what I will say instead no I am
so tired with this obsession of
something it's good look at all these
people at the top of here so what we've
got to do is bring them down when we
focus on bringing down instead of
raising up and it frustrates me I'm
sorry I'm not supposed to say it we have
a we have a challenge in this country
anywhere with the education system which
I think it's flawed in itself because we
have an obsession only with academic
grades that's the only way we measure
talent and ability and I think that's
wrong but that aside because I'm
digressing from your point
what I feel is private schools serve a
purpose there's many things that we can
do before we even consider scrapping
them which by the way I think we should
we can take money from so there are
charitable statuses they are exempt from
our majority exempt from things like
business rates court tax they don't pay
capital gains on their profits in their
investments there are many things that
we could do that we could read I've out
some of the funds from and some of the
reliefs from charity from private
schools into the state schools to to
invest funds into doing the same thing
you're now getting us into endless
conversation about the evils of private
school who cares
there's 93% oh that's not what I think
what you do and I'd actually like to
respond because I think we do can I just
say tell you what the Department
Rachel's like yes and that the
Department of Education does does have a
view on this of course and they say the
gap between standards at state-funded
schools and independent schools has
never
being smaller the UK boasts a diverse
education system in which state schools
private schools and universities are
encouraged to share their expertise and
resources through the government schools
partnership in unit and we will continue
to ensure parents have choice in where
to send their children to school that's
from the DfE right I'm gonna stick up
for parents and for private schools as a
parent who really wanted to have my kids
in the state sector I ended up putting
them in private school when they were
about ten private schools serve a
purpose in this country I can't think of
a mixed economy that has banned private
schools they contribute 3.5 billion to
the economy a year and they also and
they have two liaised with the state
sector in order that they can share
resources otherwise they will lose their
charitable status so on that day we got
to hear from the chief executive of the
girls day school trust every parent
wants what's best for their child for
some parents this means investing in an
independent school education independent
schools are fortunate to have more
freedom and resources to offer smaller
class sizes more personalized learning
and their multitude of extracurricular
clubs and activities the partnership
work done every day when independent and
state schools work together from the
benefit of all their pupils can result
in enormous and life-changing benefits
they exist it's hard to ban them in a
market economy such as we are in a free
society
having said that I'm on the record for
having said that if I could change one
thing I think it would improve society
if all children had an equal start in
life but the problem is they don't and
we've subtle from cuts and just sticking
up for the government for one second
they are pumping money back into the
state school system in order to reverse
some of the cuts and by 2025 there's
going to be another I'm going to leave
my glasses for this 25 billion for
schools there is a country that did ban
private schools Finland they banned them
they brought in to a comprehensive
education system but almost
ago and they're now held up as an
example of one of the most effective
education systems in the world look
nobody is suggesting that we take
bulldozers to Eton and Winchester
tomorrow